cette affaire a mis sous les projecteurs
les cas d'enlèvement d'enfant dans les
couples divorcés
voici à ce propos une histoire étonnante
celle de retrouvailles entre un homme et
sa fille dix ans après la fuite de son
ex-femme en israël elles avaient emmené
leurs enfants
des retrouvailles grâce au réseau
facebook sur internet
ces réseaux de rencontre n'ont
finalement pas que du mauvais sophie
rodier lorraine christophe lourd
françois delaive n'a rien oublié de ce
jour le 21 juillet 2008
ce matin-là il ouvre sa page facebook et
découvre un message en anglais qui va
lui redonner vie
avec daddy what's up sinon quoi c'est
incroyable c'est là bas que ce qui se
passe c'est un message de sa fille
disparue depuis dix ans kidnappée par sa
mère à l'âge de 5 ans
c'était un soir où il devait la
récupérer à l'école je vais la chercher
moi j'aimerais appeler le
le directeur de l'école en question qui
était une école privée et il m'a dit
écoutez de plus de nouvelles depuis dix
jours large et plus une nouvelle
aujourd'hui sarah 16 ans elle vit en
israël
deux mois après leurs retrouvailles
virtuel son père a fait le voyage
un séjour de deux semaines pendant
lesquelles ils se sont raconté leur vie
depuis ils se parlent presque chaque
jour sur internet des centaines de
messages et de photos échangées pour
rattraper le temps perdu
un espoir auquel elle était restée
accrochée pendant dix ans je me disais
que l'âge aidant ça serait elle qui
ferait des démarches et en fait mes amis
me disaient tu veux un jour elle va
débarquer l'apport de la saône et adhère
bonjour papa et c'est un peu ce qui
s'est passé quoi cette histoire qui
finit bien n'est pas un cas unique
chaque année plusieurs centaines
d'enfants sont enlevés par l'un de leurs
parents mais lorsqu'ils grandissent ils
reprennent souvent leur destin en main
et internet facilite les retrouvailles
et on s'aperçoit de plus en plus que des
enfants qui ont été séparés de l'un de
leurs parents que se veut le papa ou la
maman est bien recréer des liens sans
que l'autre le sache
avec le parent qui est loin qui est
distante ich pour lequel il n'a pas
compris pourquoi il avait été séparé et
souvent c'est l'enfant qui le retrouve
lui-même et parfois même avec beaucoup
de ténacité
la fille de françois delaive l'a
cherchée pendant deux ans sur internet
avant de le retrouver